We're going to tell you about lutetium element number 71.
It's quite a bit of argument,
whether it's the lost of the railroad or a member of group three
in the periodic table, but we'll come to that later.
We're going to show you some demonstrations,
particularly a terrific red color that you can get from it.
Yeah.
Element was discovered in 1907 by two chemists,
almost simultaneously,
French chemist shorts or BA who eventually got the
credits and therefore was allowed to name the elements and the German chemist,
Carl, our firm Valspar, who was rather older than a little bang.
They both separated it from a mixture of other railroads,
particularly from a boar containing ytterbium.
At that time, there was enormous arguments,
whether the different elements that had been isolated were really pure
or actually mixtures of more than one element and all bang
published his paper in French then eventually,
and it took a couple of years was allowed to name it and he called it
lutetium,
which is named after the Latin name for Paris,
which I think was called Lutetia. And so a very patriotic name,
which probably also annoyed Val spar,
who named his element,
Cassiopeia them after a Greek queen Cassiopeia.
I can't remember somewhere in Greek mythology.
He gave it the symbol CP,
which was there for the reason why eliminate 112 companies
Axiom was eventually given the symbol CN not to be muddled with
this non-existent element of Valspar.
For some reason, lutetium is extremely expensive.
So we only had very small pieces of the metal
And the tiny bottle of lutetium nitrate.
So we couldn't do huge experiments lutetium salts and
nearly all colorless. And I wanted to try and find the colored one.
So I read that the iodide of lutetium could
be yellow and I persuaded Neil to try mixing
potassium iodide with lutetium nitrate.
It was.
Boring to colorless solutions, mixing nothing happened.
Give it square.
We had better luck mixing sodium sulfide with
lutetium lutetium sulfide precipitated.
It was a whitish color, but with the eye of faith,
you could argue it wasn't pure weight,
but it wasn't a very convincing color.
There was still a bit of lutetium nitrate left.
So I persuaded Neil to try heating it very
often. If you heat nitrates of elements,
they will give off and no to gas,
which are Brown and form the oxide. And after a bit of heating,
indeed, you could see a Brown gas. So
lutetium nitrate behaves like other nitrates. Now,
Neil and I had both read that lutetium was meant to burn.
That's a very low temperature.
[Inaudible].
So he tried putting a piece of metal
[inaudible] metal into a flame,
and nothing happened came out just about the same.
So he got his powerful
oxygen gas torch,
which has a flame that burns at a much higher temperature used for cutting
through steel and things like that.
And then when he heated up the lutetium,
you had two samples, some small lumps,
and also a small strip of the metal.
And those really did burn.
But the real surprise to us is that it gave off a really nice
red color. And we hadn't been expecting this,
but if you've seen other elements when they burn or you put them in
the flame and some of our other videos,
you will see that elements often give a very nice characteristic
color. And so now Neil and I,
and you realize that lutetium gives a really
nice red color watch Latricia used for in the world. Well,
it's not used for very much.
You can add it to a mixture with your trim and
aluminum to make so-called Garnet,
which can be used for LEDs led lighting,
and which gives off a different color from some of the other light-emitting
diodes,
the radioactive isotope of lutetium lutetium one 77
can be used for treating prostate cancer,
a very unpleasant disease that affects a lot of men.
And you can attach the lutetium to a
molecule,
which will be absorbed selectively by the tumors.
So the radio activity can be targeted on the tumors and can
kill the tumors. Unfortunately,
it doesn't work for all the suffers from prostate cancer,
but it seems to have at least some promise, the final application,
which is more piece of analytical chemistry,
is that you can look at the ratio of lutetium and
Hafnum isotopes in objects that come from outer space,
meta rates, for example, and from the ratio of these isotopes,
you can calculate how many billions of years old
these meta rates are.
And it is quite an effective way of dating these
objects from space. This is not really a very practical application.
It's really quite an interesting piece of science.
There has been quite a lot of argument recently where lutetium
fits in the periodic table.
If you have an older periodic table lutetium will
be in group three near the bottom,
a more modern periodic table,
you will find that lutetium is right at the end of the row of
the rare earth elements.
One of the rows of the bottom of the periodic table in the separate
flock, there's still quite a bit of argument,
whether it's in one position or the other,
my personal feeling is that this is not a terribly important
point. What is an important point is that it is element number
71 and comes between 70 and 72
where it actually fits on the periodic table. Doesn't worry me so much.
But the real lesson that I got from this is that lutetium gives a
fantastic red color.
This episode was brought to you by Kiwi WICO,
sign up and get these amazing crates delivered right to your doorstep.
They've got all sorts of packages aimed at all sorts of age groups today,
I'm having a crack at making a bell Lister from the tinker crate,
which is aimed at people,
aged from nine all the way through to well people.
As old as me, everything you need is already in the box,
the instructions are super clear and seriously, this was just great fun.
I know I look a bit serious,
but that's just because I'm concentrating the future or current engineers or
makers in your house are going to love getting a project like this delivered to
them. Perhaps every month.
I can't even decide if this is educational or just playing,
which is probably what's so good about it. So not have a look through the menu,
choose yourself a crate either for yourself or maybe as a gift and get to work
the addresses on the screen. Kiwi
code.com/periodic videos that periodic videos means you're going to get 50% of
your first Cray.
I don't think it will be your last Kiwi
co.com/periodic videos.
Is that here?
We say it trim the Terbium Terbium erbium
all found for the first time for minerals from gasoline EIT in this quarry.
So we've reached the top.